aujourd'hui nous sommes à la possession
dans la rue sarda garriga recettes une
des artères principales de la commune
comme vous le voyez elle est bordée de
logements et de commerces
est-ce que sarda garriga est un nom qui
résonne dans tous les esprits
réunionnais nous allons tout de suite
les vérifier vous savez qu'il était
sarda garriga trop agitée qui a marché
sur la lune y apporter le message par la
libération
ils sont mesquins
non
c'est ce qu'annoncé la nation esclavage
voilà oui j'ai appris bien sûr à l'école
mais le nom de sarda garriga rime
toujours avec 20 décembre en 17 mois à
peine joseph napoléon sarda garriga a
mis en oeuvre la plus grande
transformation sociale de l'histoire de
la réunion
né dans le roussillon en 1808 le jeune
joseph commence sa carrière dans
l'administration des finances le 14
octobre 1848 notre franc maçon débarque
à saint denis
il a pour mission d'abolir l'esclavagé
en douceur à la veille de la campagne
sucrière c'est déjà dans l'air du temps
mais les planteurs sont contre et les
esclaves sceptiques en 1794 on leur
avait déjà promis sans aucun effet
pour éviter les troubles sarda garriga
entame mi-novembre un tour de l'île aux
seins il promet des indemnités pour la
perte de leurs biens aux soixante mille
esclaves
il parle de contrat de travail vite
interprété comme du travail forcé
finalement le 20 décembre 1848
l'abolition de l'esclavagé proclamé
l'annoncent ne provoque aucune émeute
mais au contraire une nuit de liesse
le lendemain même tout le monde est à
son poste
un an plus tard en revanche pour papa
sarda le vent tourne sur ordre du
nouveau président de la république louis
napoléon il est révoqué
il quitte la réunion le 12 mai 1850 il
meurt dans leur pauvre et oublié en
septembre 1877